hey it's me Zack Weiss Muller senior
producer at reason for the past several
months Liz wolf and I have been hosting
a show on reason's YouTube channel and
on the reason interview podcast feed
that we've called the reason live
stream before we announce what's coming
next let's look at some of the
conversations we've had already porn is
like one of the most powerful things and
if you're a teenage but you remember
being a teenage boy I remember it well
you were an early denter from the
tyrannical covid regime the really
striking one you'll see Sweden at the
very bottom of this chart because
Sweden's excess death rate during the
pandemic was the lowest in Europe This
is a shocker no one up here is going to
call you Donald Trump anymore we're
going to call you Donald Duck he's so
proud he's so sa yeah let's just let's
just look at that for a second what are
you going to do Bill to shift from the
individualist perspective to the
collectivism perspective in your
Chemistry classes in this semester
nothing I'm not going to do
it I just I hate factchecking I mean
like because the the Temptation that the
fact Checkers always succumb to is they
go beyond like factual claims there he
is on the cover of an AP article
wielding a chainsaw I I wonder whether
this will be the moment that the radical
campus and academic left breaks when
YouTube suppressed that video of a
sitting Governor uh talking to a
scientific advisers I was stunned the
beginning of the thread you write that
the aftermath of October 7th is a test
for the west and for all open societies
really is a tragically beautiful example
of how difficult it is
to
legislate kindness a lot of what
underlies uh the American culture
of trust of discourse of of searching
for the truth of mutual respect is
inherently cultural it's not legislated
you can't legislate
[Music]
it that culture of honest discourse that
Russ Roberts talks about in that last
clip that's really what we're all about
here decided to transform this into a
new show we've named just asking
questions we got exciting plans in the
works for the new version of the show on
just asking questions will continue to
bring you more of these long form
conversations diving deep into a single
topic for an hour or more at a time with
data media clips and guests who can
teach us challenge us and have fun with
us sometimes We'll Be Live sometimes we
won't but new episodes will air on
reason TV's YouTube channel at 10000
p.m. eastern time on Thursdays and on
the just asking question podcast feed on
Fridays so subscribe now to just asking
questions wherever you get your podcast
to get notified about full episodes
going forward and if you like what we're
doing here one of the best things you
can do is spread the word to friends who
you think might dig it we want to take
this to the next level and we need your
help to do it our first episode of the
new version of the show will go up next
week at 1:00 p.m. eastern time and will
be a special in-person taping with
podcaster Dave Smith given our
interactions in the past I can assure
you you're not going to want to miss
this one the title question is going to
be what is a
Libertarian join us next week to get
some
[Music]
answers